o primeiro leite por dia todo
eu acho que deveria começar falando que
devemos acreditar que nosso sonho é
possível
esse é o primeiro passo para o para o
tornar real o segundo não tão menos
importante é agir quando nós somos
crianças imaturas e inexperientes
é muito importante que a gente possa
contar com o apoio de alguém seja mãe
pai e um vizinho amigo cachorro papagaio
tanto faz mas que nos guia nessa
realização do nosso sonho
e foi assim que aconteceu comigo eu
comecei a sonhar com o mundo da dança
quando aos 34 anos de idade
tive meu primeiro contato com o balé na
creche que ficava enquanto os pais
trabalhavam mas foi um contato muito
rápido
a professora saiu da creche não pode
mais dar as aulas mas anos mais tarde eu
assisti a um filme que eu amo até hoje
existe uma borda o tema da dança e ele
despertou uma vontade enorme de voltar a
dançar mas eu sabia que era um
investimento muito alto para o paredão
da minha família mas mesmo assim fui
falar com a minha mãe pra ver se
tínhamos alguma condição de pagar uma
escola de dança
mesmo com as dificuldades mas topou
senhora comigo e depois de muito
pesquisar
ela descobriu uma escola que eu pudesse
perguntar e aí que eu comecei realizar
meu sonho agora é passado nove anos de
dança
participei participa de festivais de
dança e realizo apresentações ao lado da
minha primeira professora
esses momentos são muito importante para
mim porque eu me sinto muito honrada e
dançar em dividir o palco com a pessoa
que me ensinou os primeiros passos mas é
claro
chegar até esse ponto tive que esperar
muitos desafios
muitos tive que esperar muita dor tanto
física quanto emocional
chorei várias vezes por achar que a
pressão era muito por ter bolhas nos pés
foi muita do euro nazi e inúmeras coisas
e foi aí que eu percebi que o baleia não
é apenas pés e pernas bonitas leveza e
delicadeza
além de beneficiar fisicamente
o balé me ajudou muito no meu
amadurecimento
eu aprendi a ter disciplina a ser
responsável a ser solidário e ajudar
meus colegas ea superar os outros
desafios que apareceram até que três
anos atrás eu vou desafiada mais uma vez
dessa vez o desafio vai bater na minha
porta
uma vizinha que cuidou de mim quando era
pequena veio com pedido de ensinar valer
as suas netas e as outras meninas da
comunidade
e daí como vocês acham que eu reagir a
nada não
não foi assim senti muito medo muito
medo
então pedi um tempo para pensar porque
além dos estudos ensaio muito durante a
semana
em época de festivais tigela de
apresentações
os ensaios são dobrados mas essa não era
minha principal preocupação e sim se eu
estava pronta para ensinar se saberia
passar o conhecimento se conseguiria
lidar com várias crianças junto ao mesmo
tempo se teria tempo para me dedicar e
principalmente onde mas por outro lado
eu pensava nas meninas
dançava no sonho delas é que elas
precisavam de mim para realizá lo
então ficou decidido eu fiquei sabendo
na verdade que o espaço das aulas seria
no projeto machico
um espaço muito aconchegante divertido
o projecto bach que o projeto voluntário
idealizada pelo cláudio que preocupado
com a falta de atividades na comunidade
criou espaço nos fundos do próprio
quintal
então primeiro cláudio me mostrou como
seria o espaço era de bom tamanho mas
era bem precário
o chão é de cimento não havia espelho
nem barra mas eu sabia que a melhor
decisão seria aceitar esse convite fazer
essa boa ação
pois mas assim o cláudia seu novo
arranjo no facebook e as doações
começaram a aparecer
recebemos cerámica para o peso espelhos
uniformes para as meninas a barra o qual
deixou no ferro velho
ele pintou instalou na parede ficou
ótimo
mas mesmo assim
pelas normas do do vale' o espaço não é
apropriado o piso deveria ser de madeira
para diminuir o impacto dos joelhos
durante os movimentos mas é o que temos
e as meninas aproveitam ao máximo então
eu falei meus horários
reservei as manhãs de sábado no primeiro
dia de aula
a sala estava lotada tinha mais de dez
crianças todas lindas e uniformizados
empolgada com a nova atividade
claro que fiquei muito feliz com isso
uma coisa que eu percebi muito
importante que no começo as aulas baleia
era apenas uma brincadeira
pelo menos eu achava mas com o passar do
tempo eu percebi que se tornou algo
muito importante para as meninas
hoje temos tantas alunas que tive que
criar uma nova turma
sem contar que às vezes têm mais
crianças à procura das aulas mas
infelizmente não temos
e pedimos que nos procure no próximo ano
e nesse período eu tô no projeto
eu pude perceber a evolução nelas das
crianças e isso me deixa muito confiante
quer dizer que eu estou fazendo a coisa
certa mas é claro que como eu ainda
aprendo opala eu não posso avançar
passos com elas alguns passos pois quem
pratica balé que sabe que existe uma
técnica e uma metodologia de ensino
mas eu conto com a supervisão
profissional da minha professora e
diretora elizabete santos que eu chamo
de diabetes
ela sempre me ajuda quando eu preciso me
dá dicas me corrigir
eu também uso brincadeiras com as
crianças que ela fez comigo
assim elas aprendem brincando e quem não
gostaria isso a gente tem pessoas que
dizem que meninas gordinhas não podem
fazer balé não deve porque isso já tive
muitas alunas gordinhas que melhoraram
sua condição física depois que
freqüentar as aulas porque todo mundo
acha isso que meninas gordinhas não
podem elas podem e devem por incrível
que pareça eu sou um exemplo disso
sim é bem gordinha né jeito mas ensinar
o balé com essas crianças da sala dar as
aulas para ela é uma experiência
fascinante é maravilhosa
você aprende e ensina roupa toda em cima
conta pra gente e porque daí nas aulas
ela chegou perto de mim
envergonhados né para assim ficou fora
eu quero é igual a ti
eu fico muito emocionado porque
aí eu me pergunto o que eles estavam
fazendo agora se eu deixasse o meu medo
de dominar e não fizesse essa doação de
dar aulas de balé porque a gente por
incrível que pareça bem pertinho de nós
existe muitas pessoas que precisam de
nossa ajuda
mas infelizmente na maioria das vezes
tanto quem deseja doar como quem precisa
receber têm medo ou vergonha e acaba por
não tomar uma iniciativa
na verdade
então assim nós temos que ter coragem
para mudar nossa realidade e até das
pessoas que estão à nossa volta mas é
importante lembrar que coragem não é a
ausência do medo e sim a capacidade de
avançar vencendo o medo trata aqui neste
palco hoje eu tive que me superar muito
vencer o pior medo da da minha vida
falar em público pois é uma dança é uma
oportunidade única que eu tenho de
dividir essa história com vocês
certo mas essa história não existiria
sem os personagens principais
essas lindas menininhas bailarinas e nos
bebês com quem eu quero dividir o palco
pro inter ebba marca de do passinho
e tem fim
em briga tenha negueba só de marina quem
não tem e não tem você pergunta me
enfiei em falta de mira junto tanto
dentro
pior deixando de yu
todo mundo tenho medo nem usar o só a
marina
é e nem nunca dida nem dente por comida
nem casca de chinela não tem não liga
pra ninguém todo mundo tem nela quando
acordar às 6 da matina
como é que o braço da bailarina latina
potência medo de subir gente medo de
cair gente medo tubert gente não tem
confessando bem todo mundo faz ficar
logo assim que a missa teve
a todo mundo
em primeiro não só à tona
assim
o padre também pode até ficar vermelho
se o vento levantou batido
reparando nem todo mundo tem perdendo só
na imagem
sal assim no rio voltei na vazia
problema na família
procurando dengue em todo o globo
a marca tube xingou assim
i briga tenha a mesma chora
é e quem não tem você